-Alright, you ready for this?
-No...
-Alright!
Oww!
MMMMMM!
Fuck this!
Oww!
You're just throwing it harder in my face!
It doesn't help.
-Okay, here!
Ow, my nose!
-You can do it!
If I stick my tongue out, is that gonna be better?
-Yep.
Ow.
*laughter*
That was like, a perfect way to get it to deepthroat me.
Oww...
Why am I such a failure?!
-Very close!
I just wanna-
Yeah, please. Just see if it can- Ahhhhhh...
If it can actually embed itself in my throat.
SHUT UP!
This isn't about you! It's about me. And my pride.
Oww...
Keep going. Keep going!
I had that!
I've licked all over this, how does it feel? Saliva there.
Oh! It was in! It was in me!
It was inside me!
I'm getting like, sweaty.
Fuck.
Straight in.
-Oh, so you want it going straight?
-Yeah.
-Alright. Alright!
(Applause)
-Wow!
-Yeah!
Um...
*laughter*
Bye!